hey before the gopher I just cuz I want
you to clear something up why and what
I'm serious me uh what okay
you said that there is no effect that
the moon hasn't on the titles I mean a
bigger full moon I'm sorry let me say it
you said there's no effect the full moon
has on the tides than any other moon
yeah that's correct when you see me let
it go you couldn't know because when
sandy came I believe you okay but I'm
just saying there's a lot of people out
there that's gonna have a problem with
this cuz the news when Sandy happened
okay hurricane sandy they talked to all
about the the tidal effects of the moon
and I was a full moon this is why sandy
was so there are only two things that
affect the times from the moon the mass
of the moon is that changing that never
change okay massively higher at full
moon that it has moon no it's not a move
a B the distance to the moon okay
the moon orbits us sometimes is closer
sometimes a farther way that has nothing
to do with the phase it's an elliptical
orbit
sometimes it's closest foot forward
sometimes it's not okay right those the
only two things that affect the strength
of the tides on earth from the moon okay
so so why do we have a higher tire in
full moon because the sun's tides add to
the formulas time so let's decide the
Sun blame the Sun blame blame standing
on the Sun not the poor moon that
doodles dutifully orbits us every month
of the year
fanta don't blame the moon on that one